hey guys yeah well hold on there okay
we're good all right so the charity
livestream for living beyond breast
cancer is going on right now please
please click the link in the description
below and watch it for a whole day's
worth of games and random stuff I'm
gonna be playing an assortment of games
relaxing answering you guys's question
just talking generally eating food on
camera that's that's probably
interesting to watch so please click the
link in the description below and give
generously to this cause it's really
quite staggering because what in this
day and age it's actually gone up in
recent years a 1 out of every 8 women
will be affected by breast cancer then
that means they will either be diagnosed
with it or you know that's not they
won't die from it not all of them but
many do but 1 in 8 women every woman is
affected by it and obviously some men
too but just it's a very serious disease
and it really really needs to be taken
care of because cancer in general
affects everybody's life so please join
us for the stream we're gonna have a lot
of fun we're gonna do a lot of stuff I'm
gonna have some special guests in so
please click link description below or
my turret will come and find you